je ne peux pas vraiment vous dire
comment faire je peux seulement vous
dire comment j'ai fait trouver un
endroit confortable vous devez vous
allongé sur le dos et vous détendre
concentrez vous sur votre respiration
je suis connecté à tout ce qui existe
c'est
je vais le voir doit redéployer chez toi
alors la projection astrale permettrait
des contacts avec des êtres hors de
notre monde je pense pas que tu devrais
jouer avec ça
pourquoi vous voulez essayer je voulais
seulement regarder dans ce monde pour
trouver ma mère ta mère n'est pas ici
avec lui mais il ya autre chose
film toi moi si tu peux bouger un truc
dans la chambre tentative astral numéro
2 ça n'a pas de sens tu peux pas
enregistré ton propre esprit
ça semblait être un rêve mais c'était si
réel
ne crois pas tout ce que tu vas voir il
veut tromper ton esprit âme du christ
sanctifie mois corps du christ
que l'âme de jésus-christ locaux
c'est m'éloigne du match aller
tu a emmené quelque chose avec toi